[Music]
death and taxes are famously inevitable
but what about decomposition as anyone
who's seen a mummy knows ancient
Egyptians went to a lot of trouble to
evade decomposition so how successful
were they living cells constantly renew
themselves specialized enzymes decompose
old structures and the raw materials are
used to build new ones but what happens
when someone dies their dead cells are
no longer able to renew themselves but
the enzymes keep breaking everything
down so anyone looking to preserve a
body needed to get ahead of those
enzymes before the tissues began to rot
neurons die quickly so brains were a
lost cause two ancient egyptian
mummifies which is why according to
Greek historian Herodotus they started
the process by hammering a spike into
the skull mashing up the brain flushing
it out the nose and pouring tree resins
into the skull to prevent further
decomposition brains may decay first but
decaying guts are much worse the liver
stomach and intestines contain digestive
enzymes and bacteria which upon death
start eating the corpse from the inside
so the priest removed the lungs and
abdominal organs first it was difficult
to remove the lungs without damaging the
heart but because the heart was believed
to be the seat of the soul they treated
it with special care they placed the
visceral organs and jars filled with a
naturally occurring salt called Natron
like any salt Natron can prevent decay
by killing bacteria and preventing the
body's natural digestive enzymes from
working but Natron isn't just any salt
it's mainly a mixture of two alkaline
salts soda ash and baking soda alkaline
salts are especially deadly to bacteria
and they can turn fatty membranes into a
hard so P sub
thereby maintaining the corpses
structure after dealing with the
internal organs
the priests stuffed the body cavity with
sacks of more Natron and washed it clean
to disinfect the skin then the corpse
was set in a bed of still more Natron
for about 35 days to preserve its outer
flesh by the time of its removal the
alkaline salts had sucked the fluid from
the body and formed hard Brown clumps
the corpse wasn't putrid but it didn't
exactly smell good either so priests
poured tree resin over the body to seal
it massaged it with a waxy mixture that
included cedar oil and then wrapped it
in linen finally they placed the mummy
in a series of nested coffins and
sometimes even a stone sarcophagus so
how successful were the ancient
Egyptians at evading decay on one hand
mummies are definitely not intact human
bodies their brains have been mashed up
and flushed out their organs have been
removed and salted like salami and about
half of their remaining body mass has
been drained away still what remains is
amazingly well-preserved even after
thousands of years scientists can
perform autopsies on mummies to
determine their causes of death and
possibly even isolate DNA samples this
has given us new information for example
it seems that air pollution was a
serious problem in ancient Egypt
probably because of indoor fires used to
bake bread cardiovascular disease was
also common as was tuberculosis so
ancient Egyptians were somewhat
successful in invading decay still like
death taxes are inevitable when some
mummies were transported they were taxed
as salted
[Music]
Oh
[Music]